So one trend that I found really interesting to follow
this year is the barrel jeans
or sometimes called horseshoe jeans,
which are these jeans that become wider in the knee
before tapering down.
And these jeans have shown a 45%
increase in Google searches
and a 194% increase in Pinterest searches since January.
Trend does lean towards older millennials
and is most popular in America,
with 15% more Google searches in the US
compared to any other region.
And why are older millennials so into this trend?
I'm not 100% sure,
but perhaps it's because this
resembles the 20 tapered mom Jean,
and it's also a brand signature at brands like ally,
which tend to have a slightly older audience,
online at least.
And stick around for part two,
where I'll talk about where this trend is going
and how long it's gonna last.